hello everybody and welcome to the
third how to parse twitter tutorial um
this tutorial uh the two prior tutorials
we've already
covered everything you need to actually
parse uh
twitter now we're gonna aim to do in
this video
is uh either fully explain or begin to
explain and then finish up in another
video
how to add a little bit of logic to this
parsing
uh unlike like an rss feed or something
like that where typically
you know even like the full huffington
post feed or something like that
their updates aren't super quick right
they don't they're not pushing
articles you know really really fast
whereas with twitter
some of the topics that you might be
interested in parsing are
very high volume topics and then other
topics might be
pretty low volume except for specific
days
times etcetera so you might want to
vary your parsing a great example of
this is is
it works for news articles too but like
on twitter if you're
parsing stock companies during
the right before the trading session and
through the trading session right after
the trading session
uh volume is is going to be quite high
sometimes even as much as 300 400 500
percent
the volume that you get after that time
period so you wouldn't want to be
treating those time periods identically
i.e you wouldn't want to be pinging and
pulling and parsing and visiting
twitter as often as you might
during the trading hours now you could
set something up i suppose
that if the hour is this parse this much
but there's a much better way to do this
and that's what i'm going to show you
so with that uh what we've got going on
right here
is this makes us an array basically
and um gives us
um you know each individual tweet
now what we want to do or what i'm going
to be doing
is saying how um like how often we visit
the page
is going to be completely contingent on
how many
new updates came since the last time we
visited right
so if you visit the site you wait like
three seconds you visit the site again
and you've got a 78 percent um
similarity
you probably slow down the pings right
you can kind of slow down hitting the
website and parsing it
if by the same token if you have a zero
percent
well you probably missed something or
you got really close to missing
something
so in that case you might want to visit
a little more often
and so anyway that's what we're going to
do so let's go ahead and get into it
though
what i'm going to do is build an array
out of this we're going to add this to
an array and then we're going to compare
arrays
and with that i'm going to show you guys
a simple way to compare
arrays within python and i mean you
could say like for each item in the
array
if you know identical and you can build
you know like a ratio basically and
that's what this is going to do for us
but
uh probably it's going to use less
processing to go this way
so what you're going to want to do let's
just just showing you an example here
we're going to import
diff lib and then we're just going to
say um
we're just going to say r1 equals you
guys can follow with me if you want by
the way
or you can just watch uh because we'll
be coding out this in a little bit
not with the same parameters of course
and then two three four five
six right so in theory these are eighty
percent similar since
uh arrays uh well never mind anyway
um so now the next thing we wanna do is
we'll say compare equals and the
um be beginning to compare uh
is going to be diff lib dot sequence
matcher and then none
and then r1 oops r1 r2
and hit enter and then finally um
we'll just say you you would assign a
variable this but we're just going to
just print it out compare.ratio
and this gives us a ratio so 0.8 right
so 80 percent similar which is correct
you know four out of five are identical
so that's basically different and what
diff lib is doing so let's use
that and edit that into our twitter
parser
the first thing i want to do is let's
clean this
up here mess up
and we don't need to print the length
anymore that was just to kind of show
you guys
and then what we'll do is we'll say
instead of saying print read.sub we're
going to call this a tweet
so a tweet as our variable name equals
our sub
then we're gonna we'll we can print out
um
a tweet and then what i want to do
is let's come up here uh to our
variables
and we're gonna say we're gonna add some
local variables old twit
equals an empty array new twit is going
to equal an empty array for now
and then let's actually let's go ahead
and make
an infinite while loop so while like 1
is less than two
for example we want to perform the
following
okay so now what we're going to want to
do is
i got lost here okay yeah we're down
here print a tweet
so the next thing we're going to want to
do is let's do new twit
dot append oops don't capitalize the pen
and we're gonna append a tweet to it
and now we're gonna start let's let's
compare
the new tweet array to the old tweet
array
obviously to start there's gonna be no
nothing you know it'll be a zero percent
uh comparison but then what we'll end up
doing well you'll see let's just go
through it
so the next thing we want to do is say
comparison equals
diff lib dot sequence
matcher and again none and then we want
to compare new twit array to the
old twit array
and that's it there the next thing we
want to do is we'll
we'll make the uh variable house sim for
house similar
and that's going to equal comparison dot
ratio
and then let's oops
okay and then we want to just like let's
print another little separator just so
it's easy on our eyeballs
and we'll print house in
once we've done that uh what we're going
to want to do
is we're going to want to make sure
because
only the first time through here will
old twit be an
empty array because what we're about to
do is we're about to uh
populate the old twitter array so if
we've
already populated it once we actually
need to empty it before we populate it
so even though it's empty right now
we do need to consider what's going to
happen in the future and so we're going
to just go ahead and empty it
one more time and now what we want to do
is create a for loop and we'll just say
for each item in new twit so each part
of the array of new twit
old twit dot append
uh each item so we'll just add each
thing to it
then finally since we were adding new
things to
new twit right we're adding stuff after
we've made the comparison we also need
to clean out new twit
right so now let's clean out new to it
equals
and we'll just say none and then we'll
create a time dot
sleep and in here we'll just say five
seconds for now
but we are going to change that up and
just uno momento
so let's save that and i believe we're
ready to run
i hope so i don't think we've done
anything so let's go ahead and run it
and make sure
we're spitting out us improper shin
tires
uh let's see
i see okay we need to indent this
boom okay hopefully that'll do it let's
try it one more time
pop this over here
new twit we didn't properly uh
capitalize a new twit somewhere
let's find it it went pretty quick after
the first one so yep right here
twit so save that i'm going to close it
and reopen it
uh to re-run it so we're not seeing that
other stuff
drag it over here all right
let's see darn it i don't think we
imported diff lib
as well yeah okay we can go to the top
and import
diff lib now we save it hopefully
third time's a charm if we're lucky
oh my goodness old twit
was not defined this is driving me nuts
old capital t
try again
yes okay finally made it to the bottom
obviously the first comparison is
nothing
and we'll sleep for five seconds visits
again now we see the second comparison
is 57
similar um so we could probably have
slowed that down a little bit
now we've got a 70 percent uh similarity
and we'll go again 74. so you can see we
definitely could slow this down but how
do we do that
based on the percent of similarity that
way we have to go through each topic
and specify you know a specific wait
time
well since we want to wait longer
like the bigger this number of
similarities the longer we want our
weight right
so why don't we mult use that number to
multiply so
i vote we say time sleep equals how
sim times
uh we'll do if it was a hundred percent
so
i don't know let's say like eight or
something like that let's try that out
and see how that works with this guy
come over here
so zero percent similarity it sleeps
nothing i
should probably thought about that next
71 so it's
0.71 times eight now we've got .61
so it's going to be times eight so
obviously we want to bring this number
up a little bit higher
so let's make it times let's try
15 because really we have all the way to
go until close to zero i would say you
wouldn't want to see
numbers like frequently under 10. so
let's
let's say 15 as our wait time
bring this back over obviously zero is
going to go pretty darn quick and
now we've got 85 so 85
and we'll be sleeping for 15 or well
85.85 times 15.
so what this is going to do anyway while
we wait um
it now that's good now point 32
similarity
and so on so what it's going to continue
doing is kind of slow us down a little
bit
so i would even argue that really you
want to have something
that the first time it goes through its
wait time it'll be too much maybe but
then
at the end of it you'd want maybe 0.30
times
so maybe you'd want your weight time to
be even like 30 right because now this
is going to bump us down again
because it's pretty high
so as soon as i see the next one we'll
do
yes we definitely have room to grow so
we'll or to go down a little bit so now
we can say like
30 or something like that and probably
the best way to solve for this
um you know inconsistency right because
it's going to keep going up and down
right
because the next time see right now it's
95 percent so this is going to wait a
really long time and then we'll see the
next time we hit
it probably going to be either maybe
zero or barely zero so we'll see let's
wait till it hits here
and we
it was 15 there we go wow those look
almost perfect day
oh man yeah the next one's like wait
ketchup
yeah okay so anyway uh you get the point
now what i would wager
uh would be an even better idea is
instead of using how similar times you
know 30
what you might want to do is use the
average of maybe like the last
five house similarities to denote your
your current wait time that way you
don't because what is going to happen
here is you're going to do a lot of whip
sawing back and forth and back and forth
and back and forth
so instead you might want to fix that
now this in theory i believe over time
would stop
like like slowly stop whip songs so much
but
anyway so that's at least a naive way to
go about
um parsing twitter
and having a little bit of a wait time
now in the next video i'm going to show
you guys
uh i think what we'll do is we'll build
an array
of um we could just build like a long
long term array but i don't think that's
going to react fast enough so you want
something
you know like this is highly reactive
right so if if all of a sudden there's a
huge explosion
you know of new tweets you definitely
want your array to be very reactive but
at the same time not too reactive to the
point where it's reacting to itself
right so so the next one i think that's
what we'll do is we'll add
a bit of an array and then we'll work
off the average of all those numbers
we'll need at least three but i'm
thinking of doing probably five and then
i'll help keep it pretty stable
so anyways as always thanks for watching
hopefully uh help a few of you guys out
thank you for your support your
subscriptions and until next time